so we're told the square below
represents one hole so this entire
square as a hole and then they ask us
what percent is represented by the
shaded area so why don't you pause this
video and see if you can figure that out
so let's see the hole is divided into 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 equal sections
of which 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 are actually
filled in that's the shaded area so one
way to think about it is 7 tenths are
shaded in but how do we express this
fraction as a percent they're asking for
a percent well remember percent it
literally means per hundred cent same
root as the word hundred you see it in
cents or century and so can we write
this as per hundred instead of per ten
well 7 / 10 is the same thing as 70 per
hundred or 70 percent and how did I go
from 7/10 to 70 over 100 well I just
multiply both the numerator and the
denominator by 10 and once you do more
and more percentage you'll get a hang of
it you say Oh 7/10 that's the same thing
as 70 400 which is 70 percent let's do
another example here we're told 100
percent is shown on the following tape
diagram so just this amount right over
here is 100 percent and then they asked
us what percent is represented by the
entire tape diagram so by this entire
thing right over here pause this video
and see if you can answer that well one
way to think about a hundred percent 100
percent is equivalent to a whole and now
we have three times as much of that for
the entire tape diagram so you could
view this as three wholes or you could
say that's a hundred percent we have
another hundred percent right over here
and then we have another 100 percent
right over here so the whole tape
diagram that would be three hundred
percent let's do another example this is
strangely fun alright okay and I'll see
it says the large rectangle below
represents one hole all right so that's
this whole thing
is one hole what percentage is
represented by the percent shaded area
so pause the video and see if you can
figure that out again so let's just
express it as a fraction first so we
have a total of 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11
12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19 20 squares so
out of those 20 squares we see that 6 of
them are actually shaded in so 6
twentieths can rewrite that as per
hundred well let's see to go from 20 to
100 I multiply by 5 and so if I multiply
so if I multiply the numerator by 5 I'll
get the same value 6 times 5 is 30 so 6
/ 20 is the same thing as 30 per hundred
which is the same thing as 30% which
literally means per hundred so this is
30% let's do one last example here we
are told each large rectangle below
represents one hole so this is a hole
and then this whole thing right over
here is another hole what percentage is
represented by the shaded area again
pause the video see if you could answer
that so this one we have shaded in a
hole so that is 100% and then over here
we have shaded in 1 2 3 4 fifths of the
hole so 4/5 if I want to express it as
per hundred what would it be well five
times 20 is a hundred so 4 times 20 is
80 so 4/5 or 80 hundredths is filled out
here or you can say 80 / hundred which
is the same thing as 80% so this right
over here is 80% so what percent is
represented by the shaded area well we
have a hundred percent and then we have
80 percent so we have one hundred and
eighty percent it's more than a whole if
you have a percentage that is larger
than 100 percent you're talking about
something that is more than a hole and
then we see that we have a hole right
over here and then we have 80 percent
more than that